a Brazilian fugitive accused of
murdering her husband is back on US soil
to face justice thanks in part to 48
hours karl Harig was a major in the Air
Force Reserve he was shot and killed in
his own home back in March of 2007 the
main suspect in the case was his wife
but she flew back to her native Brazil
shortly after Herod's death 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty has been
following this case and joins us at the
table to discuss good morning Erin good
morning all Carl herrings family and the
prosecutor in Trumbull County Ohio have
been tried for more than a decade to get
his wife Claudia back to this country to
face charges in the death of the
American military hero but Brazil has
refused to extradite its native-born
citizens until now a weary and at times
teary Claudia Harig was arraigned last
Friday morning charged with the
aggravated murder of her husband
decorated Air Force pilot major Carl
Harig he was amazing he was actually a
very good pilot but he was a better
person we are here today solely for the
purposes of an arraignment one count of
aggravated murder now 53 Claudia looks
nothing like the woman who fled the
country in March 2007 three days before
police found her husband shot to death
Paul Herrick is Carl's brother
my oldest brother called and told me as
soon as he said Carl's dead I already
know who did it I knew it was her Carl
had been married less than two years to
Claudia a Brazilian native the marriage
had fallen apart and Carl was
threatening divorce he was shot with a
357 revolver and an investigation shows
that just days earlier his wife had
bought one investigators believe that
after shooting her husband Claudia flew
to Brazil a country that refuses to
extradite native-born citizens but
American officials argued Claudia gave
up her Brazilian citizenship when she
signed an oath to become an American
citizen years before her marriage to
Carl she's the one that left she's the
one that should come back last fall Paul
Herrick traveled with 48 hours to Brazil
to push for Claudia's extradition it
makes me mad to know that she was living
such a comfortable life and you know my
brother's dead Paul never expected what
would happen just three months later the
phone rang there was Dennis Watkins on
the other end he said she's back with
God her clàudia hair I completed not
guilty is expected to go on trial within
the next year and is being held on a ten
million dollar bond officials say that
Paul Herrick strip and that's Carl's
brother to Brazil with 48 hours made a
real difference in this case I think he
put a face on the victims I mean
honestly just make it that you didn't
see this coming no I did not and I got
it home Wednesday night last week the
prosecutor Dennis Watkins didn't even
give his name he just said she's in my
jail and I was like I hate to say you
didn't call me she didn't tell me so I
could be there but yeah it's it's a
surprise because this has never happened
that a native-born Brazilian has ever
been extradited interesting Thanks